Madame C racontez-moi comment ça s'est
fait comment le début de l'histoire à
quel moment vous apprenez qu'il faut que
vous disiez à vos citoyens de quitter
vous savez monsieur Rouen les feux on
contrôle pas ça puis des fois la
situation change très rapidement hier
soir à 5h tout était ce contrôle on se
disait le piste scénario c'était
l'évacuation pourrait faire environ
d'ici trois jours si la tendance se
maintient mais 2h30 plus tard j'ai eu un
appel puis on dit Madame
faut déclarer mesure d'urgence le feu a
progressé beaucoup plus rapidement qu'on
s'imaginait et l'on n'a pas le choix
faut aller aller de l'avant alors à 8h
et quelques j'ai fait la l'annonce aux
citoyens et je dois vous dire Monsieur
ouais que ça a été extraordinaire de la
manière que les gens m'ont fait ça parce
que ça a été fait dans l'ordre ça a été
énorme vous imaginez au plus de 7000
personnes qui partent de leur communauté
qui prennent la route c'est la 167 qui
se rend jusqu'à rode verval donc ça a
été un bouchon qu'on dit en trafic mais
ça quand même bien été malgré tout et
les gens ont fait ça puis vous savez
c'est avoir des citoyens quand on évacue
parce que il y a un danger il y a une
raison pour laquelle on le fait et cette
discipline là il se résilience j'ai
trouvé ça extraordinaire